- [Announcer] (mumbles) Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience applauds)
- Hello, hello, hello.
Great, I just wanna maximize the time
before I have to catch
this flight to Atlanta,
so thank you for listening.
Please grab your food, I
see where the mics are.
So there's three people there?
I'm just trying, just getting context.
Alright, why don't we go, go ahead, sir.
What's your name and what's your question?
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
so my question is actually
what your experience
may be with crowdfunding
and businesses that run
primarily on crowdfunding,
the sustainability of that in the future;
possible issues that
come up with how states
are looking at taxing crowdfunding
and keeping (murmurs) with it.
- Look, I think even
if, point, the evolution
of crowdfunding gets harder
and not as Wild, Wild West
and it changes the
dynamics, it's hard now.
Like, crowdfunding is really fascinating
'cause people get excited
when they hear about
the one startup that gets
like a million dollars
from a bunch of people, but like 98, 99%
of crowdfunded companies that are posted
don't reach their goals or
get to where they're at.
So my answer is this:
it will be a model that
I genuinely believe
will always be out there
because it's native
to the internet, right,
we're more connected,
it makes sense.
But I think it's gonna
come down to the thing
that it always comes down to which is
I'm not against it, I like it.
I like it the same way as
pitching a high-net worth
individual to give you a million dollars
for the piece, you know, there's
a million different ways,
we're living in an era
now where people don't go
to the bank for a loan anymore,
and that was the only
way we did it in 1989.
So things will evolve in funding.
I think it's a viable platform.
I wouldn't overly worry about
what it's gonna look like in 2027,
and I would just focus on
what you're doing right now,
if you like it, if you
have a knack for it,
if you're good at it.
I think you can milk it and squeeze it,
but you recognize they'll be evolutions.
- [Audience Member] Alright,
it's fuckin' awesome.
Thank you.
- (chuckles) You got it.
Go ahead, my man.
- [Carlos] Hey, Gary; yeah, we love you
over here, man; I'm Carlos.
- Over here as in Phoenix or
over on this side of the room?
- [Carlos] I came from
Sacramento, see you.
- Respect, man, thank you.
- [Carlos] So me and my business partner--
- Thank you.
So me and my business
partners, we got a great core
of employees, they're
loyal, they're ride-or-die,
but then there's a good portion of them,
and I see revolving door.
They fall off--
- Yup.
- [Carlos] And that
really hurts the company.
And, you know, we're--
- [Gary] How much time
are you spending speaking
to those individuals one by one?
- [Carlos] So we do
individual conferencing
when we're seeing them
struggle all the time.
- What about before then?
- [Carlos] Before they start to struggle?
- Yeah.
- [Carlos] You know, its like we--
- How many employees do you have?
- [Carlos] There's not
much, I'd say about 32.
- Yeah, so to me, the
fact that you've decided
to make this your
question, I'm jumping ahead
'cause it's awesome and easy.
How many partners do you have?
- Two.
- Right, so three total?
- [Carlos] Yeah.
- The fact that there's
only 10 employees per,
or 11 employees per person,
you need to go all in, bro.
You need to do a once-a-month with 10
of the employees breakfast.
You need to then take the other 10
and meet with them every month.
Like, in the beginning of Vayner,
before it got to like so many
that I knew that I just couldn't scale,
I was really sticky, DMing them.
Like, being a boss is
about, and being an owner,
is about reverse
engineering your employees,
not them conforming to you.
If you're upset about the revolving door
and that's affecting you,
you need to figure out
how to get stickier.
The way to get stickier is to figure out
if it's (audio distorting) acknowledgment,
title, like what makes them tick.
The end.
- Got it.
- You know, it might just
be an extra dollar an hour
on that level, right?
Or it might just be the fact
that you even gave a fuck
to take them out for a
coffee that made them stay
an extra 18 months.
An employee told me
flat out that buying him
St. Louis Cardinal tickets
early in his career
at Vayner made him pass on other offers
offering him 40,000 more a year.
So everybody here's, you
know, and think about
your lives right now.
If you've been in the workforce or career,
there's been times where
you valued money more,
you wanted respect more,
reputation, balance.
It's not only figuring out
what the six things are,
it's the six things today,
which is why it never ends.
- Got it, thank you.
- You got it, bro.
Yo.
You're good.
- I'm good?
- Yup.
(murmurs)
- What's up, Garry?
- How are you?
- I'm Nate from LA, so--
- It's a pleasure.
(murmurs) on that TV.
(Gary chuckles)
(murmurs) fun of my gaming stuff.
But I kinda don't really have
that much of a practical question--
- Okay.
- [Nate] You kinda put me into position
to where I basically run myself now.
Like, any question I
have, I met with Debbie.
- Good.
- [Nate] And I just wanna ask, like,
what do you, like, can
you actually comprehend
how much impact you
actually have on people?
If you don't, like to put you context,
I came from someone that's just like
a scrawny little insecure
little Asian kid,
and to someone that just learned how
to look for you, like, (mumbles)
you're sort of like a father-figure.
Not only me, but like a lot of other kids.
And to me, it's like, yo,
like I'm in front of him,
so like in running, I'm making six-up,
on my list to be making six
figures from nothing, you know.
And it's, how do you talk with
(mumbles) impact (mumbles)?
- So really interesting question,
and like I don't even wanna answer it
with this many people in the room;
you'll appreciate where I'm about to go.
It breaks down to a couple things.
Number one, the reason I don't hear that,
back to getting high on my supply;
the answer is yes, like people like, Gary,
do you even know how many
people you're affecting?
I'm like, yes.
I get fuckin' 10,000 emails a week
of people telling me that they
were about to commit suicide
and stopped because of my content,
or they were in debt and now they're not,
or they used to be mean to their wife
and now they have the best relation.
So the answer is, like,
I think I'm gonna impact
every person on Earth if I'm lucky enough
to live long enough,
which is a ludicrous thing to say.
It's unbelievably audacious.
I genuinely at this
point want to be the most
impactful human ever, why not?
- Woo!
- Why not, why not?
(audience clapping)
But the reason it's
palpable and not obnoxious
is 'cause, when I hear that compliment,
that's a much bigger
compliment to my parents
and America than it is to me.
I'm a byproduct of circumstance.
So I don't lose my way
because I don't think it's me.
Does that make sense?
(mumbles)
Thank you, man.
- What's up, Gary?
- Hey, man.
- [Audience Member] I
got you on the IP line.
- [Gary] That's good.
- [Audience Member]
(mumbles) you got put as many
pieces of content--
- You're making content, bro.
- I'm taking it right now.
- You also musta saw
my blog post a couple
months ago about wearing
ridiculous shirts.
- Hey, man, I gotta stand out.
- Let's go, baby.
- Gotta stand out.
First I wanna say thank you for telling me
a million fuckin' times
to turn my camera on
and make a video if I
got something to say.
Did it, and it changed my life.
- (chuckles) Go figure.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, I know right,
who woulda fuckin' thought.
I'm in the financial advising,
financial planning industry.
What do you see as the
future of that industry,
and how can I make the most
impact to young people?
- It's less about what's the future,
it's more about you're right on it.
Like, you need to make more content, bro.
If you don't have a very serious
LinkedIn content strategy,
you're leaving a huge opportunity.
You're a young dude, and
you're gonna gravitate
towards IG video, easy,
but LinkedIn is fuckin' gold
right now for everybody.
LinkedIn organic reach is
more (audio distortion)
organic reach was doing
five or six years ago.
It is just an opportunity.
And I don't care if you're
selling weird t-shirts,
figure out how to make it
business oriented in LinkedIn.
Everybody here should really
think about how to make
their content work to professionals.
If you're in the roofing business,
like title the post why lawyers
and HR executives need better roofs.
I'm not joking.
So for you, bro, heavy content on LinkedIn
before LinkedIn's organic
reach starts declining too.
- [Audience Member] For sure, for sure.
Thank you.
- You got it, bro.
- Hey, Gary, Suzy Sly.
- Hi.
- [Suzy] Just thinking about
five years ago for (mumbles),
and I can't believe (mumbles) jets.
- Thank you.
- This is my question,
I know you're a savvy tech investor--
- Did you notice that I
replied to your tweet just--
- [Suzy] Just this second, Dan, yeah.
- Just a like, this is a funny meta-moment
'cause I think it can be a learning moment
to like truth, living your truth.
I'm jumping in and interrupting her
because while I was walking
from the stage to her,
I replied to her tweet
that she just posted
about me keeping it real onstage today.
I drink my own Kool-Aid.
When I yell at you for not replying
to your 13 comments on
your last Instagram post,
it's 'cause still at this point,
with hundreds of thousands of comments,
I'm living it.
- [Suzy] I just replied to that one
while I was waiting for you.
- Alright, I'm fuckin', I'm
on stage, I'll get to it,
Jesus.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member]
(mumbles) send as well.
- Go ahead.
- So my question is this,
I'm in the middle of a
pre-siri-bay funding round--
- Okay.
- AI company--
- And I know you're a savvy
tech investor: what makes
a successful tech startup
versus those that tank?
- What I've seen is the combination,
where I've made my money
and where I've lost my money
is on the delta of the
two things that matter:
the idea and then the timing of that idea,
which you're gonna deal with with AI.
And then honestly, the
thing that in the beginning
I was great at but then I
did get a little too high
on my supply off the winds
and I started just betting on the idea.
I was at my best, and I'm
back to being that person
when I bet on the person too.
Like, I can't, I would look the other way.
You know what I did poorly,
I would hear a business idea
and I could dream what I
would do if I was running it,
and that's when I
thought it would be good.
But I didn't realize,
like, I'm not running it.
And so what makes a
success in my opinion is
I believe in the idea,
the idea's timing is right,
because that's where people get killed.
Like, AI is gonna happen.
When?
AR is gonna happen.
You know how many people
poor tons of money
into virtual reality 18 months ago?
We're not even close, nobody here uses VR.
Like so, timing, idea, human.
- Alright, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Audience Member] Hey, Gary,
I'm (mumbles) a huge fan,
I've got 10 of my friends
here 'cause (mumbles)
you're like fuckin' music, poetry.
Awesome--
- Thank you, bro.
Where are your 10 friends?
- Over there.
(audience cheering)
- Why are all your friends eating?
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Go ahead, go ahead.
- Thanks, Gary.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member]
Not including shoutouts
to your friends or family,
if the next few words
you're were gonna say
would be the last words
you would say on this Earth to pass on,
what would they be?
- Thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
I am so fascinated by gratitude.
Like, I'm so weirded about human traits,
I wonder, this is gonna make sense;
by the way, this is the
downside of failing science,
you're about to see it play out,
'cause I'm asking you guys a question.
I'm excited about thinking
that the way science
is evolving, we'll be able to go get
not be 12 shots but like gratitude shots.
Like, besides health,
boy, would I wish for you
to be disproportionately
empathetic and grateful.
Because if you are, you
will live one happy life.
And so my answer would be thank you
because if I could ever
convince all of you
that the pontificating I do
around 400 trillion to one,
which is the current math
that scientists believe
is the likelihood of
becoming a human being;
if you actually sat
here while you're eating
your fuckin' salad,
and you actually let that sink in,
like for a second, almost wanna
go like zen meditation shit
and not talk,
400 trillion to one
that you're a human.
Like, how can't you be
grateful for the at-bat?
I'm just so grateful,
man, I would say thank you
because I'm so grateful.
Like, I fear death my whole life;
nightmares as a kid, today I
think about it all the time.
Out of one thing, the love of life.
And that's not how much
money I have or followers
(audio distorts) just playing my game,
thank you, by the way;
getting to play my game.
I just wanted to get this last part out.
Like, that's what I want, I
want people to play their game.
Because you're also talking to
somebody who played his game,
you're a shitty student,
you're gonna suck.
I grew up looking around the faces,
there's enough people here who remember,
the '80s and '90s and even early 2000s,
that's the golden era of good college
is the only way you win.
And then the world came to me.
It wasn't cool to be an entrepreneur,
there weren't entrepreneurs
that had t-shirts
that people wore.
And then the world came to me
because I never wavered from my place.
And so maybe you love
painting with tomatoes.
And maybe it seems ridiculous today,
let me tell you how many of my friends
at 17, 18, 19, 20, 21
should've just stayed playing video games
and not try to become a lawyer.
They'd be making a lot
more money and being
a lot happier today.
Nobody over 40 in this room,
growing up the way I did,
saw professional video
game playing a profession.
All the moms told us to
get off the fuckin' thing
and go be somebody who goes to college
and takes $300,000 in debt
and never gets out of debt.
Like, guys,
how many examples do
you want me to give you
to tell you that you don't
know how life's gonna play out.
It's why I love making choices.
I hate when people are
like, Gary, I'm crippled,
like, should I do this or this?
I'm like, pick one, they're like, ugh.
I'm like, if you pick
one, you do understand
you'll never know what would've happened.
The reason I don't struggle
with making decisions
is 'cause I know that I don't get to see
how it would've played out.
So I don't know, we need
to get way more basic,
but the answer is thank you.
(audience applauding)
Hi.
- Hello.
- How are you?
- [Ruth] I'm good, healthy.
How 'bout you?
- Amazing.
- Well my name is Ruth.
And one of my questions is,
can I take a picture with
you after the mic question?
- [Gary] You can.
- My question (mumbles) is,
so I have a question about legacy
because, and this is
something I account for
the longest time that threw the years.
I know there's other business owners
who are just like building their business.
And I've always wondered how,
when they have, like how
do they keep that going.
- [Gary] They don't.
They're dead.
- [Ruth] Okay, but
there's also people that
keep it going for them.
- That's right, but you
can't control the world
from the grave.
So, like, are you asking what's
the best way to make sure my business
is being run properly once I'm gone?
- [Ruth] I think it's more of,
like if it's making such an impact,
how does one keep that impact going.
- Well that's the reason
I'm so unbelievably
passionate about making
content and putting it
on the internet.
This question and
interaction that you and I
are having right now is
being watched right now
47 years after my death.
I'm aware.
So you want legacy, produce content.
You want, that pontificating
I just did up there
about having a vlog and making content,
it may not turn into your
million-dollar business.
I promise you you're
gonna have a real laugh
with your granddaughter
in 39 years watching it.
Content.
You know, people used
to be lucky that their
grandfather or grandmother were famous,
and so there was like
old films about them,
and they had things we didn't have.
We had like 17, 29 pictures.
Like, everybody in this room should
be the patriarch and
matriarch of their families
in perpetuity because they're the ones
who are now alive during
the era of content creation
at scale, and there should
be more content of you
than anybody prior to you,
thus you're the starting point.
Literally, I genuinely
believe what I'm about to say:
this room is the starting
point for their family.
Because in 130 years,
they're not gonna know
your great-grandparents,
but you're going to be
that person, so I would produce content.
Alright, picture.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Colleen] Hi, Gary,
my name's Colleen Ty.
- How are you?
- Great.
- And I run and lead a nonprofit
called the Arc-a-ten-gi.
We serve adults with intellectual
(mumbles) disabilities.
And we serve them through helping them
basically find a
(mumbles) in the community
and the greater community
outside (audio distorts)
- Okay.
- [Colleen] What is, my question falls on,
speaking with donors and having people
in large group like this is hoping to gain
for our group of having
community engagement
and having a diverse group of people
be at those (mumbles).
I found that long donors don't see
the important thing, they
think of it as all fun.
Oh, you want money to take
them to the illumination.
Well that's not necessary.
No, though, the grind of
life and what we have all
been (mumbles) and see the route to being,
it's not really working for everyone.
- So my big thing with
nonprofits is a couple things,
and I sit on several boards
and spend a lot of time
thinking about the
marketing of nonprofits.
The biggest vulnerability
for nonprofits is ideology.
Like, it's very awesome that
you're passionate about this.
- [Colleen] Very.
- But he just might not be.
And the ideology and even audacity
of some of the people that
work or run nonprofits
is the thing I'm trying
to get them out of.
What I'm trying to get
the ones on involved with
is, like, cool,
let's not convince anybody of anything.
Let's disproportionately create stories
and let the people that
actually care about them
consume them.
And it's a very important framework
if you think about how I
just talked about that.
Don't waste a minute
trying to convince somebody
who can't be convinced.
- I get it.
- Right?
I mean, you know this.
I don't want you to be
disappointed anymore.
That your passionate about
it, I'm passionate about
(audio distorts) 'cause my brother has it.
Like, we can't judge.
I love when people judge.
And that's what a lot of nonprofits do,
just 'cause you're a fuckin' nonprofit
doesn't mean you're owed anything.
It's amazing that you're
doing something amazing,
so now let's focus on people
who we think are, right?
And so I think it's
about content, marketing,
and most importantly,
the mindset when we go
and talk to people,
about being appreciative
to even get the at-bat to
get them to hear about it.
But bailing really quick,
like if I'm pitching him on,
hey, we're gonna have this (mumbles),
and I could see his eyes are glossing;
thank you so much, man, have a great day.
That's how I live my life.
I don't expect anything from anybody
about anything that I'm talking about.
And the second I get an
indicator that they're
not interested, I'm not mad at them,
I just wanna move on to the next thing
because there's fuckin' 400
million people to talk to.
It's a big mindset shift
for a lot of, profit land.
You understand?
- Yes, I do, thank you.
- It's a big deal, if you
really use that filter,
you will be stunned by
the adjectives and words
you use on email, phone
call and social media
that will become the
unlock for you actually
getting what you want.
- Okay.
- Make sense?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
It's super important, that
was an important moment
for a lot of people, like,
when you change your
mindset, back to the kind of
weird thing I was doing onstage,
like, I could even see where she was,
that was fine, I didn't wanna let her go
because I could tell she's
like kinda getting it.
And it's important to get it,
because it goes back to entitlement.
When you're as wonderful as she is
and you're doing something
so important for the world,
and you see people buying
fuckin' Lamborghinis
and fuckin' 80-dollar this,
and they don't have time for you in this,
it's very easy to start to judge,
but that becomes your downfall.
And when you don't have expectations,
and when you're not entitled,
well we're a nonprofit, you should.
I hear that so much in
nonprofit boards I'm in:
you should, you should what?
It's not like we're sitting down with you
for four, you might
have a sick grandmother
that you have to take a
percentage of your paycheck to.
Just 'cause you're, like,
you should do nothing.
You should be a decent human being,
but how that manifests,
right?
And everyone's posturing.
It doesn't take much to put out a tweet
that says #MeToo, but how are you actually
living your life, got it?
So we need to eliminate
entitlement and judgment.
Once you do that, you're in giving mode,
not expecting mode.
Once you're in giving mode,
a very funny thing happens,
you start getting.
It's not how many likes
or followers you get,
it's how much value you're
bringing to the people
who decided to follow
you in the first place.
All of a sudden, a funny thing happens.
All of a sudden, the nine
people that give a fuck
about you today tell seven other people,
because you actually gave a fuck back
for them giving a fuck in the first place.
(audience chuckles)
Hey.
- [Audience Member] I
know you're a family man.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] I
own a small business,
I often have high school,
middle school students
helping me with production.
- That's awesome.
- I also have,
work with my own.
And I was just wondering
what your advice is
on teaching them how to balance
not caring what others
think and being able
to do what they love but
also showing respect.
- By holding them accountable to respect
but not creating an
ideology of what respect is.
Right, where I think people struggle
is they've decided to
manifest what respect is.
The thing that I've been so
fascinated by the world on
is, for some reason, we've decided that
writing a letter to
somebody and sending it
is some greater act than sending a text
with the same words on it.
That the reason we're
shitting on kids today
is 'cause they don't look you in the eye
when you shake their hand.
Like, the key is actually understanding
what is actual respect and kindness,
not the current state of
what's politically correct
in its manifestation.
That's it, so, you know,
that's how I'm,
I'm really paying attention
to what my two are doing
and watching everybody else.
I hate when are like, these kids,
they don't know how to socialize.
They're more social than we were.
These kids go online and
social with hundreds of kids
on Twitch and Instagram
and YouTube all day.
What did you do on a
random Wednesday in 1986?
Let me remind you.
You threw a rock in the fuckin' water.
(audience chuckles)
Like, it's crazy.
We shit on the new generation,
and we put our generation on an ideology.
Do you know what my
contemporary girl friend,
friends that were (audio
distorts) in high school?
They ran into their room, locked the door,
got on their second phone line
and were on the phone
for seven fuckin' hours
before they went to sleep.
Sounds like being on your phone all day.
Judgment, so you know what,
you're their mom.
You know what respect is.
If you became ideological and you said
shaking a person's hand, like, fine.
That's up to you, I will
never tell anybody to parent.
But I will tell you, socially
commentating on the macro,
old people start putting
old shit on a pedestal,
and that's some bullshit.
(audience laughs and applauds)
Do you remember the
outrage of Miley Cyrus'
VMA appearance seven years ago?
That's like a lame Instagram post.
(audience laughs)
Like, go read what we wrote about
The Beetles' long hair
and the extreme disrespect
it was to our society.
Don't get old.
Stop being full of shit.
(audience chuckles)
- Gary, hey.
- Hey.
- [Audience Member] (mumbles)
scared without people
getting out of their own way.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] Number
one is, a lot of your
language is reinforcing two things.
So upstairs, we reinforced 7,000 people
to just post a bunch of shit,
and not qualify that it's good content
as opposed to just ridiculousness.
And then the second thing that potentially
I wanna ask you about reinforcing,
especially on this last
question, this last thing is,
I find myself judging and questioning
the use of vulgarity.
At which point in time is it justifying it
and making it essentially
popular or acceptable,
and at what point does it
just become rude and vulgar?
- I think intent.
I think one of the reasons
I've been able to curse
maybe more than others is 'cause I think
humans are actually
unbelievably good at having
intuition around intent.
And I think for a lot of people,
they're like, if I had
to bet my life on it,
that's just a Jersey boy being Jersey boy,
not somebody who's trying to use it be,
I mean, brother, like the
other thing is the truth.
Go watch my videos on
YouTube that I posted
in 2009, '10, '11, I get
destroyed for cursing.
Oh, Steve's not, like I wish my CAA,
you know, we just
started a speaking bureau
where Zach, who was my CAA rep,
is now my, I wish he was
here right now to tell you
how much money I lost
in 2009, '10, '11, '12,
and how they would beg me.
They would say things, I mean,
they would try to bribe me,
they were like, we've
got 500,000 in advance,
five speeches, when I was
making 30,000 a speech.
So this is a big jump, 100,000 a speech.
But you can't curse,
and it needs to be like the
beginning of you not cursing.
And I was like fuck you!
(audience laughs)
Because I'll tell you
where it is, my friend,
I think you'll understand
this and I think I can tell
why you picked up on that, it's intent.
I'm not cursing for the sake of cursing.
This is how I'm comfortable
in communicating.
As a matter of fact, I wish I didn't
because I would be bigger.
(audience chuckles)
You know?
The alpha young males,
I would them without it.
But all the people I'm
losing because I curse,
the amount of people
that judge me and think
I'm a bad person 'cause I curse
would be staggering to you.
You just have the capability
of seeing through that
and seeing the truth
and the humanity.
Like, if I spoke with
a little less energy,
a little less bravado,
a little less Jersey
and a lot less cursing, I
would be seven times bigger.
- But boring.
- It's not about boring,
just, it wouldn't be me.
- Exciting.
- It just wouldn't,
it's not even exciting, you can be,
like I watch a lot of standup comedy,
there's great people who don't.
It's just not my truth.
- [Audience Member] Who
is seven times bigger
that's doing that?
- I don't know, to be honest,
I so don't know what the
fuck is going on out there
'cause I can't hear anything.
I don't know who speaks, I don't,
guys, I've never seen
Tony Robbins speak in his,
like, I don't consume content.
- [Audience Member] All
you do is consume content.
- Your content, your content, right?
I don't consume other people's
book or podcasts or shows.
I just read your comments.
That's how I know stuff.
You think I just lucked into
having great understanding
of human behavior?
This is fuckin' 20 years of just reading
every single person's point of view
on every single goddamn thing,
at scale.
Of course I'm gonna be
good at trend-spotting,
it's pattern recognition
of what's made people tick.
We don't change, the landscape changes.
We're animals.
That's why I know who insecure we are.
That's why I laugh when you guys blame
social media for what's going on.
It's the mirror.
Blame traditional media
(audio distorts) in a world
where we know the (audio distorts).
This is the step backwards
for the two steps forward.
We've gotta reconcile our shortcomings,
it's being exposed.
So you know, I don't want,
you know to be frank, I'm
not pumped I'm vulgar.
I take no pride in cursing,
I don't think it's cool.
I really don't, I really don't.
I think it's me, and
I don't know how to be
anything but me.
You want a real life
lesson, figure that out,
shit gets good.
(audience applauding)
(audience member mumbling)
Yeah, sure.
Do I have to, what's going
on, few more minutes?
- Last question.
- Okay.
- [Moderator] This is
Gary's last question.
After this, main session
is starting upstairs.
- Shit, better make it a good one.
Nice shoes, by the way.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Audience Member] So
speaking of gratitude,
I'm having a little bit of a,
kind of moral dilemma in my head.
(mumbles)
So I shoot (mumbles)
photography and I post
photos on the Instagram.
I really could be, not nearly
as much as I need to be,
but on (mumbles) regular basis.
- Okay.
- [Audience Member] So when
one of my images gets stolen,
and there's no credit given
where they're using it
for their own purposes,
on one hand, I'm like,
dude, you son of a bitch,
you stole my image.
But on the other hand, I'm oddly grateful
that my work is good enough to steal.
Do you draw a line--
- Nope.
- Somewhere there, no?
- I draw a line in, I like,
thank God you have the second part,
and now I will try to
suffocate you in perpetuity
to not give a shit about the first part.
- [Audience Member] Okay.
- People spend all their time on defense.
And that's why they lose.
What are you gonna do, chase them down?
(audience chuckles)
With what?
What are you gonna slip into their DM
and be like, you're a dick?
What are you gonna spend nine hours trying
to figure out where that person lives
and not call them?
Like, what the fuck are you gonna do?
You know what I would do,
if it's bothering you so much?
Leave a comment on that post and be like,
yo bro, thanks so much for using my image.
- [Audience Member] Nice, nice.
- [Audience Member] I've
done that before (mumbles).
- Do it every time.
- Good.
- And never worry about
somebody stealing your image.
'Cause stealing images
in a 2019 internet world
is different than 1974 in print form.
It's a different game.
- Got it, okay.
- Cool.
Thank you, everyone.
(audience applauding and cheering)